l'événement culturel de ce 1er janvier
avec que la réouverture de beaubourg une
rénovation entamée il ya plus de deux
ans réaménagement et réhabilitation
technique
un immense chantier qui s'achève ouvert
gratuitement au public cette fin de
semaine avant l'inauguration par jacques
chirac le 11 janvier prochain
daniel wolfromm gagnent richard une
heure d'attenté voire plus en ce milieu
d'après midi le centre pompidou est au
bord de la saturation
nous on laisse tomber ya trop de monde
et la queue est bloqué à l'entrée
il fallait donc bien du courage et de la
patience
à l'image de ses tout premiers visiteurs
accueillis par la ministre de la culture
en personne
vous êtes arrivé à l'heure si le béton a
remplacé la moquette dans le hall une
signalisation coloré et vigoureuse
oriente le public sous le regard
toujours présent du fondateur georges
pompidou le derrière les bureaux
d'accueil toute la journée le président
du centre en personne les deux derniers
étages sont entièrement consacrées à
l'art grâce à cette rénovation le centre
pompidou est devenu le plus grand musée
d'art du xxème siècle au monde 600
heures supplémentaires ils sont exposés
un parcours qui commence aux prémices de
l'art moderne des pièces devenues
désormais des classiques pour se
poursuivre avec le design des années 70
et finir en compagnie des dernières
trouvailles de l'art contemporain c'est
bien ce bien est rien on sent pas et
pourtant j'y ai beaucoup de gens on sent
pas étouffer le magnifique le splendide
il ya énormément de monde et en fin de
compte regarder on a l'impression
j'ai produit sonne mais on n'est pas
bousculé l'administration du centre
elle a déménagé la bibliothèque publique
a pris sa place
ces deux mille lecteurs pourront ainsi
bénéficier de la vue imprenable sur le
quartier aujourd'hui on la visite
mais on ne pourra pas y travailler avant
le 26 janvier
enfin la fameuse chenilles l'escalator
extérieur du centre pour l'emprunter il
faudra payer le billet du musée fini les
visites gratuites sur les terrasses
maintenant l'arsem eric hahn